uh welcome Bella
so Billet is just doing this in the
studio Bella you made your first draw in
this tournament it's a very unusual
result for you Yes actually this so I
decided that maybe it's time to make a
one draw in the tournament so when
harika chose this variation actually I
played this um a few weeks ago in Grand
Prime exactly the same position yes
exactly just I was thinking to choose
this lane or line or not but then I
decided that maybe it's good good option
because I feel really tired and
especially after yesterday's game
we actually checked your head to head
score and did it have an influence on on
the variation because like you never won
against harika it seems
and also she has a very wide opening
Clipper tour and to prepare it's also
not easy so so how far did you know here
uh to this move Yes actually no water
Bishop thoughts
first line I think our rookie 8 and Rook
D5 yes
we were trying to find some Advantage
maybe here for white but yes this is a
very forced line
[Music]
so now that the tournament is over uh
what is like your general impression
about the event oh I'm enjoying playing
here it does not matter the results I
love playing in Saint Louis and I want
to say a big thank you to the organizers
first of all Mr and Mrs singfield what
they do for the development of the chess
it's incredible really and thank you to
all the staff you made this tournament
really great
so I'm really happy
to be here thank you Bella and yes sir
Nazi well first of all uh
congratulations Bella I know for you it
was a real roller coaster ride you
started with those two losses but then
you snap back with the four wins just
tell us about your emotional up and down
uh for this event
you know yes it was
harmful to those first two games and
especially childish I lost first in my
my first game so
I was trying not to worry a lot about it
and to concentrate on my in other games
and it worked actually
oh congratulations uh really a a fine
result and we hope you come back to St
Louis yeah
thank you for such fighting games and
showing that you can start badly and
then come back and win four games in a
row exactly